واوكرانيا تعتمدوا العتاد والسلاح الرقمي
كيف ذلك اوكرانيا اليوم قامت بتحميل
قواتها المقاتله الى صيغه رقميه ساعدتها
في التغلب على الاله العسكريه الروسيه
خلال ضمان مقاتلين شبكين رقميا
ومعلومات استخباراتيه وفقا صحيفه واصل
جانال شبكه الجيش الاوكراني التي تضم
عشرات الطائرات بدون طيار والاصله
والاسلحه المتطوره والاتصالات عبر الاقمار
الصناعيه والبرمجيات المخصصه باتت تمنح
للجنود الاوكران مستوى كبير من المهاره
والتنسيق والدقه وتسمح لهم باداره ومتابعه
تمركز الجيوش الروسيه ضخمه
هذه المتابعه ادت الى نجاح اوكرانيا في
توجيه ضربه قويه لروسيا من خلال رصد هواتف
الجنود الروس في مكيفكا
[موسيقى]
ووفقه مراقبين نجاح اوكرانيا في تجميع
نظام قياده وتحكم افتراض سريع سريع يقدم
دروسا قيمه للغرب لا سيما حول الحاجه الى
تجربه وتضمين خبراء غير عسكريين حيث قام
المبرمجون الاوكرانيون بتحديث النظام يطلق
يطلق عليه الجيش اسم دلتا لمنح القاده
المحليين معلومات استخباراتيه عن ساحه
المعركه في الوقت الفعلي والتي يتم تلقيها
من طائرات بدون طيار ومن مراقبين يعيشون
في الاجزاء التي تحتلها روسيا في اوكرانيا
وبالتالي الجيش الاوكراني سيكون الاكثر
تقدما في المرحله المقبله وذلك من خلال
بناء معدات ووحدات تشويش بطائرات بدون
طيار محليه الصنع ويصنع ايضا وحدات
بطاريات رخيصه عاليه
ابقاء الجنود متصلين بالانترنت اثناء
القتال وهي قفزات للرجيه في 10 اشهر فقط
ويتمثل احد عناصر نجاح اوكرانيا في كيفيه
عمل الوحدات العسكريه المختلفه
وشركات التكنولوجيا الاوكرانيه على ثقه
تقنياتها العسكريه الجديده التي تضمن
رقمنا امنه تربط القاده والمقاتلين
والاسلحه والاستخبارات
[موسيقى]